cerca de 34 millones de argentinos van a
las urnas este domingo su voto definirá
las listas de candidatos que quedarán
habilitadas para competir en las
elecciones del 14 de noviembre el
presidente alberto fernández cerró
campaña con un llamado a la unidad de
todos los argentinos
ante la oportunidad que nos da la
historia de empezar de cero y construir
otro tiempo
yo les pido que el día sean
a los que nos votaron en el 2019 a los
que no votaron y hoy dudan a los que no
nos votaron les pido por favor que el
día 100 estemos juntos para terminar con
tanta desigualdad para terminar con
tanta decadencia para terminar de una
vez y para siempre con el dolor que esta
pandemia nos ha dejado y que tanto dolor
no haya sido en vano
el 14 de noviembre se votará para
renovar 127 de los 257 escaños de la
cámara de diputados y 24 de las 72
bancas del senado en las primarias de
este 12 de septiembre los electores
tendrán que utilizar tapabocas lavarse
las manos respetar el distanciamiento
social de dos metros entre otras medidas
para controlar la pandemia de kobe 19 en
los más de 17.000 centros de votación
habilitados en todo el país vamos a
realizar un proceso electoral en medio
de una pandemia
compatibilizando el derecho a votar con
el cuidado de la salud gracias al
consenso alcanzado con los bloques de la
oposición pudimos ganar cinco semanas de
vacunación donde se aplicaron más de 12
millones de dosis
los comicios de este domingo están
marcados por la difícil situación
económica que atraviesa argentina cuando
la inflación supere el 51 por ciento una
tasa de desempleo del 10,2 por ciento y
una caída del poder adquisitivo de los
salarios